whoa whoa commentary from them walking
around no one cares about summer salad
while we talk about that is the ultimate
disrespectful move of - Taylor
commentaries it's like I'm not I'm not
taking a lunch break well no I'm gonna
try just as hard as men in black
international dead but you the viewer
get to watch us talk about thought
process behind right thinking you eat
believe scenes viewer questions and
comments and then a tease for not just
next week's honest ray stop whining
you're gonna get more yeah yeah I'm more
concerned about the fact that I called
him Lincoln's and not planket than I am
about talking about this that was being
like your lame aunt trying to relate
very funny yeah the older we get it just
happens it's like my mother-in-law calls
her Britney Spears or your celebrities
or whatever so and the brain starts to
go brain starting to go just I mean they
had a slot they must just had a release
date and an IP in their in their war
chest and said nicest thing I can say
about this movie is that it exists yeah
yeah this was the closest I think we'll
ever see to
people making a movie under duress like
someone had a gun too everyone said they
were all just trying to leave constantly
or fix it and just no one wanted to be
there yeah I mean as we bring up in the
trailer there's a as so often happens
after a big critical and box-office bomb
happens everybody starts blaming
everyone there's like there's like a
nine sourced tell-all article in one of
the trades afterwards yeah and this one
was no exception F gary Gray tried to
leave a lot there was many drafts of the
script that were supposedly good and
edgy and like you got to mention there
it was somewhat better to get those two
to sign on right first play yeah but how
can they make that much worse because
one of the producers has final cut and
there was just a lot of back-and-forth
and you know I guess it's a miracle that
this ever came out but you should just
you just don't have to make a movie no
the dialogue it was like it's the
equivalent of like lorem ipsum like
every punch line was like yeah I'm gonna
write this in and fill it in for a joke
later yeah we'll punch this up later but
none of it got punched up so it's just
it's just bad so it's hard to describe
because it's like like you know when
we're talking about a movie that's so
boring and just so by-the-numbers it's
like describing the taste of water it's
like I can't tell you exactly where it
went wrong except that like you just are
watching people sleepwalk through an
action buddy comedy yeah it's very room
temperature yeah it's just weird cuz F
gary Gray has a director like I've liked
some of his movies I've not liked some
of his movies but regardless the one
thing his movies always have is like a
very kinetic energy and app
repulsiveness to it and like this felt
like you know like a one of those like
nameless three name directors from the
early 2000s whoever did who Paul WS
Anderson yeah do Resident Evil I don't
know
even his movies have like rises and
falls and differences in pacing and
jokes yeah yeah I know this is the
fundamental thing and I think blonde
brought this up whose elsewhere but it
was like they the main characters don't
have a bit if you have a buddy comedy
there's gotta be a bit yeah ones this
ones that if you're gonna wear the
uniforms you gotta sell the cookies yeah
I've got to sell them cooking and they
were both two things
they were both yeah kind of snarky but
kind of dump and kind of by-the-book but
kind of rebels they were both brilliant
but also both stupid when the script you
did them to be stupid but that doesn't
work you can't have you shouldn't really
have one character like that you
certainly can't have two characters like
that yeah and then have them spend 90%
of their time on screen together right
just being nothing yeah it was
definitely I think yeah like F gary Gray
was just like no I'm out and then in the
meantime someone had to step up and just
be like well just do whatever Tyco YTD
told you to do in thor ragnarok be
charming
we got about 20 more minutes you're in
the suits we got the set there's a
practical shoe puppet that's an alien
next to you guys just those shoes
weren't practice do the tight gun also
what alien would evolve to look like
shoes never mind let's just take a big
bite of salad and watch men in black
international yeah let's talk about the
third act button that we didn't put in
the truth
[Music]
you've seen them visit outerspace secret
prisons on the moon even travel through
time
now I'll follow the men in black on
their most exotic out-of-this-world
destination yeah go back to that little
rocket I mean that stubbier Ray's thing
yeah that little dick ship he's riding
they have this whole chase scene in a
Marrakech bazaar which I believe is
contractually mandated when you shoot
bizarre thing you know of course like he
figures out oh this thing goes up as
well and you know they've run through
their cliches I think a lot of people go
oh and drop it over there and stand up
to a bastion RSQ shakin a monkey true to
date quizzically he notices a big button
let's go we've run out of
the usual things you do the bazaar in
Marrakesh perhaps this get out of scene
button really go to the next book it
just teleports them like yeah 50 miles
to the south because I'm gonna be very
honest with you because this is honest
trailers there's large portions of this
movie that I stopped watching mm-hmm and
I think I'm okay you'd be forgiven to be
like you know Marrakech Bazaar chase
closed eyes 15 minutes and then when I
open my eyes will be in the next team
captures the requisite we're stranded
let's do some character development
scenes yeah boy
so yeah it was a get out of scene button
dick ship they're out-of-this-world
destination yet been in black
international hot areas that find a
deposit
yeah fun that was the only thing they
carried upper than I like but what was
this movie called in Europe it's not
international like it all took place and
it was London Marrakesh London it was
called men in black pre brexit Europe I
guess so yeah yeah I'm gonna try to look
at that unless I'm blacking here - no
sickness and bland of a franchise built
around Will Smith goofing on a bunch of
grubby white guys but they're throwing
out there from the formula in favor of
something much more daring stick to
beautiful people on screen together and
hope they're funny well it's not gonna
save itself are you saying that you need
me to save the world uh-huh
oh that sounds like a joke it's a
placeholder for a joke to be written
later almost like an alien dressed as a
person can almost sound like a person
yeah look I don't deny that I would
laugh uproariously at anything either
Chris Hemsworth or Tessa Thompson said
to me in that cadence in person right
but played back and through the magic of
the Olman television
Oh what do you got there Oh in in the
languages that I'm able to decipher in
anyway it was released largely as a
minibike international around the world
it says in France it was released as
Minh and black international now to take
a big bite itself
oh you send them give each other thumbs
up it's dead
let's just end the scene this way okay
moving on I don't know it was hard to
protect making these too funny or Hitler
Tessa I that's the one line in the trail
that I'm like cuz I don't think anyone
could have made any of this funny no I
don't because they're very talented and
I think in the hands of the production
that cared or like bothered to I don't
know get dressed or wear pants or
remember to breathe on set they could
have had a cool men in black movie like
there but yeah I don't know did they
know none of it was landing I guess you
don't when you're making a movie it's
hard yeah it's hard to look at it on the
page I mean but when your director is
like no I don't want to do this like 20
feet away
contractually obligated at some point
testing the hemsworth they're probably
looking at each other like this is bad
not good I'm buying a boat with this but
this is not yeah all right well yeah I
don't know
Hemsworth this made me laugh in other
things where he's playing like him bow
you know you could say him busters he
was funny in that and you know Thor he's
playing like a big dumb Brody guy and
it's like Marvel funny it's not actually
funny and then there's just Thomson's
like quirky funny like sorry to bother
you she was like crazy funny but neither
of them I don't know I don't know man I
think that aren't they our celebrities
were actually funny some are Chris Evans
I think is actually funny actually funny
no I'm sorry
[Laughter]
looks like a standin like he's a
gargoyle like a sexy gargoyle yeah leave
the jokes for the rest of us Ferrell is
funny yeah do you mean like like like
like how we're talking about poster boy
celebrity too funny yes but like yeah
some people do violate that but I don't
Jon Hamm is funny it's pretty funny yeah
that's right that's pretty hams funny
but it's usually playing off the reality
of like I'm Jon Hamm I like sweat
Cologne and Spanish Fly is like oozing
out of me but Jon hands
jon Hamm's can hams it's pretty
funny on the joking again it's like it's
about having the bit and having someone
direct them properly because there's no
jokes and the other men in blacks it's
just will well risk saying things and
going haha it's like it's character
based because it's like he's rigging and
then time Lee Jones is it's funny like
to have him react he knows his job they
both know they know it they didn't know
their job giving them jobs to do they
could have done their job but no one
gave them jobs
I don't know it was harder for Tai Chi
making these too funny or Hitler is a
code name that was thankfully still
available while Chris Hemsworth is agent
age a guy who's both great at his job
and a lazy screw-up sorry so in this top
agent / total loser team's up with a
rookie who's by-the-book / completely
reckless the results will be so muddled
it'll feel like each actor hired their
own personal screenwriters because they
did nice I hope you didn't pay extra for
this one separation policy they've gone
for protecting the galaxy to letting
alien frat boys have their way with us
short he wants to be sure on a good time
are you pimping me out to fungus yes
aliens arrived we can disguise
themselves as humans you know like every
other alien they'll use their powers to
reshape the earth around them just Eve a
gun with the power to reshape the earth
around them because the g-baby is
trusting might be with a weaponized star
to protect the Yankees maggoty I mean
how dumb is it that this movie like the
MacGuffin was like a gun that's a star
but who cares like think it was a gun
that could like shoot a hole in the
ground like a very large hole like we
don't have that
on earth guns and bombs and stuff like
they needed to come here to it was a
really powerful gun this one goes to 11
yeah this one reshapes the earth right I
don't know man like weren't the other
men in black'''s like they were about
saving the entire galaxy yeah or yes
they were
now it's arms-dealing yeah but like
small arms dealing they lost me at your
baby and all the way he's a slob when
they go to Rebecca Ferguson's house for
no reason
yeah yeah I did watch some of that yeah
wasn't beast there beast was beast was
there for Sonic the Hedgehog that
randomly happened to be the same alien
that that she has to Thompson met when
she was and I remembered her yeah if you
like saved him and then he like went on
to kill a bunch of people yeah yeah no
he was like a vicious killer but but he
liked her so it was all good talk about
dork stuff we're working on one that's
all about thank you God God with the
power to reshape the earth around them
because the Jew baby is trusting might
be witty weaponized star to protect the
yakety smack it is Lee Mason is a real
bad guy at the end shocker I take you
two hours now ghost goes through the
Tessa Thompson Co Twitter it's way more
thought out and it's actually funny and
Sony just bought the movie rights didn't
they want to see them aliens this movie
Scott oh and while some of them are
racial caricatures Bailey normally
what is this equal to the notebook oh
it's just so yummy you many more would
they be attracted to us I'm conflicted
here because I do still subscribe to
Donald lovers solo theory of there's so
many things to have sex with in space
that we would all be attracted to each
other okay fair enough
mm-hmm but yeah every alien given a
speaking line in these movies it's very
thirsty that brief interaction though
that you saw between Tessa Thompson and
Chris Hemsworth that is the that's the
core of what's wrong with this movie
they're both they're both trying to get
the joke right like they're both the
part is written so that they're both
like jockeying to be the one that lands
the punchline it's like you can't have
it's like going to a boxing match but
the boxers just like shadowbox in their
corners remember Mel Brooks Dracula dead
and loving it there's this ability but
there's a scene where Mel Brooks and
Leslie Nielsen are doing the we're both
trying to get the last word bit and it's
just this dumb thing we're like Mel
Brooks gets the last word and then 30
seconds later like Leslie Nielsen walks
by outside and like he gets the last
word he's like oh and that's this whole
movie just that scene from Mel Brooks
definitely underrated Dracula dead and
loving it
if nothing else go watch Dracula jokes
in it it's good yeah that's true yeah
with jokes yeah after many after many
frustrating social engagements I have
instituted a three comedians are lesser
role three delightful somehow four or
more I've just boxed out it's just a
competition it's so I'm watching a
sporting match I didn't buy so you guys
are in
gonna see our Herald team perform it's
so great every Tuesday and Thursday and
I do you guys use your Facebook event I
deleted face you know I get so many hard
copy fliers shaken not stirred I'm sorry
I don't
[Laughter]
we sure F gary Gray actually directed
this because it kind of feels like
someone's trying to get fired
oh happy times baby isn't deserve press
up like the bouncer at a country club
and fetish sighs gods like it didn't go
out of style because once the 21 Jump
Street crossover failed and instead
passed a new bad boys 3 you were about
to experience the minimum viable studio
product that technically qualifies as a
movie something is wrong yeah can I get
my memory wipe too please oh my brain
what happened why am I in a recording
booth ooh
they made a new man in black movie with
Doren Valkyrie that sounds cool it was
worth it sorry to bother me I did it for
maybe a week not even trying to be funny
yeah
Nanny McPhee James P Sullivan and the
twins who also had to be in cats in 2019
was not their year tough year to be a
dancing 20 but dancing
or you know this is the second Will
Smith sequel to not actually feature
Will Smith but references character with
an oil painting on the wall in fact
right now someone out there is working
on an oil painting for Suicide Squad -
I'm obsessed with that specific it's
like so hyper cific why do you want to
remind us of a better movie right like I
remember watching it if it's a
resurgence it was weird
that they had like an ting of him on the
wall in the way it's like duction still
it's like a production stuff but like
this one again it's like is it it's like
it feels contractual at this point like
if there's a real Smith sequel that he
is not himself in he must be
memorialized physically via an oil
painting oh my god that'd be an amazing
thing to have in a car do it man it's
got a gallery that he's working heart
show yeah maybe it just happens after
they for a big event happens in a movie
like in ghostbusters 2 and that painting
changes from Vigo to their having the
baby mm-hmm
maybe I feel like a portrait of Dorian
great thing where he has eternal youth
because he keeps getting his soul
traveling no one is gonna be four bright
to the precinct that was the best cop
[Laughter]
yeah it's got to keep it going he does
have there been any other sequel city
hasn't been in that we need to
retroactively Lee put oil paintings in
there's already two suicides got two and
bright too I don't think he's ready
there one of those um but there's enough
time for both of those yeah the rest of
them were okay - were they doing an
ollie - is it like a queen thing where
they are the crown type thing where they
the cast a new ally every decade okay
yeah after earth not make another effort
plans man bad plan man yeah what happens
after nothing let's keep going maybe
Jake I think we have a deleted scene
maybe Jamie hates them that's nice
he's a good kid you're uh that's like a
six-hour flight from New York could you
maybe try just a little bit harder movie
was perfect pausing that train - all
right this is some of those doesn't make
the trailer okay so this this this the
subway train pulls in and it looks like
a real actual subway train right
underneath men in black headquarters
underneath men in black headquarters and
the only people that you ever see enter
or exit the subway are men and black
people or aliens right so it would see
that the subway train is only meant for
aliens and men and black people that
know that men in black exist Karanga
across the ocean going and but then it
transforms and goes across the ocean but
yeah if it's a train that's only for men
and black men orders to each other then
why did it ever look like a subway train
other than they wanted to do this
expensive thing where it transforms from
being a subway train to it fancy men in
black I build a train at all windows
balls from Mortal Kombat to annihilate
already there's the StudioLive just grab
on and um men in black yes there was
like this vast conspiracy thing but it
still smoked it still smelt it still
felt small enough that it was a
one-in-a-million chance that Will Smith
this cop chase to this guy and
discovered that he wasn't alone in the
universe this movie fantastic beasts
itself like now everything is an alien
thing everything is men in black stuff
every train is also secretly a men in
black train have all kinds of divisions
oh yeah it's just like I would think
break up men in black by country they're
like a planetary yeah agency if anyone
yeah
if everything's gonna be men in black
stuff then just like drop the pretense
that it's a secret thing and make the
comedy that now earth
he knows that like 60% of its population
is aliens why would the London branch
name their own head a obvious British
pun that no one that actually lives in
this high tea like that's an American
making fun of the UK and then they make
it so that they wouldn't office would
never do that why the head of the
American office hire a lady just because
the lady hit on her she was like I'm
giving you a gun what's confusing and I
stopped paying attention it was like we
weren't already there the worst part is
like the she doesn't hire her because
she likes it gets horned up but she does
she hires her off-screen she does this
battery of tests like a remember that
first minute black
super fun it's like Will Smith at the
firing range really just like a little
girl and then like the hijinks ensue
this one it's off-camera she's watching
an iPad she's watching she's watching
her computer at her at her desk and just
like graphs show up like good that's
when she decided to hire which is a dumb
word yes I was gonna say yeah and she
had it and she had a gun before that I
think or no getting a gun was part of
the montage sorry I'm really hung up on
hey rookie here's your gun now go to
orientation keep playing what's a point
hi I'm starring Star Wars regarding
Tess's management PI T get it because
he's in England Ra's al Ghul release
whoa actors silly pawn poly Yanni
silicon falling Shiba nonsense and
sensibility silly and twins ride
Thor and Valkyrie floor from home
planetary International International
planetary men in black International
that's the last time you'll ever see or
hear about it from us but you guys had
things to say um for non-dual are for
not for nan blarp this movie I'm sorry
you have to be okay with us thinking
down it's not cool that that yeah and I
hope Sony still employs you or whatever
all right Andrew fest nur do you feel
like men in black has enough gas in its
creative tank to make more movies or
should they have stopped after three one
after one personally would have loved to
see the 21 Jump Street crossover yes I
guess I feel like they could have you
know lamp shaded the fact they like this
is a to Dead franchise your weirdness
and cynicism of that would have made it
fun yeah
should that flashing thingy Mariko tree
registered that flashy thing you ever be
invented which movie with the SJ panel
members want erased from personal memory
Austin Powers 3 yeah that's not good
I'm trying to think of something that
like actually makes me cats us off the
table by the way
I'm trying to think of something that
like actively makes me mad bright made
me mad but now I've got a healthy
distance from it and it's a part of me
mm-hmm so I don't wanna do because the
Latinos were orcs you see would it be
possible that I would then go back and
watch the movies again later though only
to be reduce appointed memento yourself
just like Danielle do not Cleopatra
Jones killed my wife no no I'll have to
think about that later I would never go
see transformers 5 if I didn't have to
so if you were erased it from my memory
then I would never seek it out and watch
it so that's what's were the only way
out I would say without doubt that I
would never seek out and watch on my own
so I let's say transformers 5 yeah every
now and last one
LT net Jack and Lance Turley both wrote
in about how dumb it is that that the
naming scheme for men in black agents oh
I guess there's only 26 ages in the
world
they're branches and non-english
speaking countries that use letters of
their language our letters reused if one
dies or retires so how do you refer to
past occasions that confuse with other
ones I've used the same letter I agree
all great points yeah great point
because because there we've seen far
more than 26 men men and women and women
in black men actually you know I would
watch the the South American men in
black with like agent n yay and I think
that would be cool and you know much
better I did like that Daniel you
referred to the the ex women moment and
yeah and dark Teaneck says the this
movie did very much the same thing like
yeah I'm gonna address the thing but not
really yeah but we did it Internet man
we said uh we said something that you'll
recognize but the thing was doubly
inexplicable because it's like on one
hand I thought Emma Thompson ran men in
black so she's like I tried and like it
didn't work out she's the boss and
she's in charge who's up there saying is
it the gyri to the paper yeah is it like
a built-in situation where like some
arbitrary contracts is that he's in
charge of naming right anyways yeah yeah
couldn't you change it
you'd one would think I guess you can do
puns you can branch out into like high
tea so it'd be like maybe that's why
they named him hide - yeah cuz there was
already a tea but is there also like
governor yeah there's like we started
calling the men in black like some dude
in Oklahoma was like I swear to God I
seen them boy yeah why would they call
themselves yeah you know what we were
already workshopping a few other names
but that works like thanks Jed it's
weird to me oh man alright let's stop
thinking or talking about this movie
this week is one of our most prestigious
honest trailers yet it's a black man by
national is there I say the men in black
International we may or may not do it
come table seekers around but we have a
nother oz trailer coming out tomorrow
get your butts right back here and then
come back some point later for some
commentary of sorts thanks for watching
right after the Oscars so if you're
listening this long congratulations
watch the Oscars then watch screen
junkies and see what happens then thanks
for watching bye bye
[Music]
you